muy bien digamos que tenemos la función
f x igual a 2 x + 5 entre 4 - 3x y lo
que queremos hacer es encontrar el
inverso de esta función pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo antes de
que lo hagamos juntos ahora vamos a
resolverlo juntos como repaso de lo que
es una función y su inverso recordemos
que si tenemos que este es el dominio de
la función es el conjunto de todos los
valores que podemos usar en la función
como valor de x y que van a dar una
salida o resultado válido digamos que
tenemos una equis que es parte del
dominio y si yo calculará la función con
este valor de x como entrada entonces la
función va a entregar un valor que está
en el rango de la función a este valor
le llamamos f x en la función inversa se
hace lo opuesto si usamos como entrada
el valor de fx en la función el
resultado va a ser igual a x esto es
exactamente lo que hace una función
inversa
como encontramos el inverso de una
función especialmente si la función está
expresada como un enunciado racional
como éste pues la forma en la que yo
pienso en esto es que digamos que es
igual a la función en x por lo que
podemos decir que es igual a 2 x 5 entre
4 menos 3 x para la inversa se va a
intercambiar la relación entre xy por lo
que en la función inversa se cumple que
x va a ser igual a 25 entre 43 y para
poder expresar esto como función de x o
para decir que es igual de como función
de x para la función inversa ahora
necesitamos resolver para allá
hay que usar un poco de álgebra aquí
veamos si podemos hacerlo lo primero que
haré es multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por 4 menos 3 y si lo hacemos
nos queda del lado izquierdo x por cada
uno de estos términos menos 3
y esto es igual al lado derecho que como
lo multiplicamos por el denominador nos
queda el numerador 25 esto puede parecer
un poco intimidante porque tenemos x 10
pero recuerden que queremos resolver
para y vamos a reunir todos los términos
con de un lado y todos los términos que
no tienen en el otro lado vamos a quitar
este dossier de aquí por lo que restamos
12 de ambos lados de la ecuación y
también vamos a quitar este 4x del lado
izquierdo préstamos 4x de ambos lados y
que nos queda del lado izquierdo queda
menos 3 y x menos 2 y quizás no sepan
qué hacer con esto pero les mostraré en
un momento y esto es igual a estos se
cancelan y queda 5 menos 4x
recordemos que queremos resolver para
ayer por lo que vamos a factorizar la
lleve acá y nos va a quedar por menos 3
x menos 2
que es igual a 5 - 4x y ya estamos en la
recta final dividimos ambos lados de la
ecuación entre menos 3 x menos 2 y nos
queda igual a 5 menos 4x entre menos 3 x
menos 2 otra forma de expresar esto es
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por menos 1 lo que no cambia
el valor y nos queda 4x menos 5 entre 3
x + 2 aquí lo tenemos la efe inversa
como función de x es igual a ésta ya que
es igual a esto de aquí